Julia Valentina is a recognized expert
in impact investing advising family
offices high net worth individuals
governments and banks around the world
on development and implementation of
impact investing programs in addition to
teaching impact investing at the
University of st. gallen in Switzerland
she's on the board an investment
committee of CFM the development finance
institution of Switzerland she holds an
MBA and PhD from the University of st.
Petersburg Russia and is a chartered
financial analyst Noah Beckwith behan
began his career at the economist group
covering Africa and the Pacific for the
economist intelligence unit and the
economist newspaper thereafter he spent
12 years creating private equity funds
focused on the small and medium-sized
enterprise sector in Africa Asia and
Latin America with a Commonwealth
Development Corporation and oreos
capital he is now an independent advisor
to multilateral Development Bank's
development finance institutions
foundations and family offices on impact
investment strategies noah holds an MA
in Modern Languages from Oxford
University and an MSC in development
economics from the London School of
Economics Julia and Noah I'm so glad
you're here and delighted to have this
conversation about how you impact the
philanthropic space with your knowledge
of impact investing starting with you
Julian it is astonishing that you were a
senior executive of AIG and you adopted
this frame of impact investing how did
you come to do that well I think
realistically looking back it probably
was the birth of my first child I
started investing 18 years ago in 94 I
would with a BB financing and developing
large-scale energy and infrastructure
projects around the world primarily in
emerging markets and there you kind of
see that each investment has impact with
a positive in terms of saving
environment and energy efficiency
renewable energy or negative we had
issues with
three gorges dam in China which had
social negative impacts and then I moved
to AG and I was managing director ivett
equity portfolio which was you know a
glamorous job but after the birth of my
first child you kind of think what are
you doing it for why are you spending so
much time away from your child if you
don't do something which is meaningful
and I wanted to go into her philanthropy
and NGOs but then I thought that
actually combining the commercial
approach with the philanthropic
objectives in one would create a very
impactful strategy and that's how I
started developing the impact investing
found aig